ready to go i think okay
all right i'd like to call the meeting
back to order after our recess
and i would like to welcome commissioner
quinn
uh it's uh it's a pleasure to uh
to see you and um i understand you have
a
uh wonderful briefing prepared for us
and so if you would uh like to start
i think we are ready for you well good
morning representative embargo
and um honored uh
guests i just want to make sure steve
lavoy is on
uh yeah i am here uh nikki is is there
any way to turn our cameras on
uh you should be allowed to there's
nothing restricting
you are in here as a panelist steve so
you should be good to go oh
how about i hit the start video button
yeah that'll work
there we go thank you yes i'm here hi
everybody yeah i realize steve this is
well well good welcome good uh good
afternoon everybody um
my name is robert quinn i'm the
commissioner of the department of safety
and with me today is steve laboy who's
my director of administration
and i want to start by saying steve does
a fantastic job and i'm truly
uh grateful to have him in this role
today we together will present the
governor's recommended fy 2223 budget
for the department of safety
the mission of the department of safety
is to continually enhance the safety
security and quality of life in new
hampshire through professional
collaborative and innovative service to
all
i'm honored to to lead this dedicated
team of professionals in the department
of safety
and proud of how each division has
responded to the challenges of covet 19
whether providing support for the covert
19 response
are making significant changes to
business processes
to ensure that public safety services
continue to be limited
during this unprecedented time
developing a biennial budget is
challenging under any circumstances
however the impact that cobra 19 has had
on state revenues made this budget
significantly harder to compile demand
for public safety services continues to
increase
salaries and benefits increase combined
with increased equipment
replacement cost the law enforcement
accountability
community and transparency as we all
refer to as lee act recommendations and
our increased reliance on i.t
infrastructure and systems
have all increased the cost of doing
business
these increased costs must be balanced
by weaknesses in general funds
highway funds and turnpike funds which
resulted in a decrease in funding
available to the department
specifically 7.1 percent decline in
general funds
9.7 decline in turnpike funds
and an 11.5 decline in highway funds
this budget funds all existing public
safety services required to maintain
public safety in new hampshire through
fy 22 and 23.
however funding constraints will result
in some reductions in delays in service
in certain areas we've worked extremely
hard to make the difficult decisions
required to minimize
the impact that funding restrictions
will have over the next biennium
specifically this budget more accurately
allocates retiree health and doit costs
across all dedicated funds to reduce the
draw on the highway fund and general
fund
this budget reduces operating costs
including reduction to equipment
replacement
and part-time funding to the minimum
amounts
necessary for the continued delivery of
public safety services
this budget shifts some general funded
to existing dedicated funds to ensure
uninterrupted delivery of services in fy
22 and 23.
these adjustments will need to be
revisited in fy
2425 to address concerns surrounding the
long-term health
of these dedicated funds finally
this budget unfunds 50 existed
existing full-time positions nine of
which are currently filled
throughout the presentation today myself
and steve will discuss how these
unfunded positions will impact public
safety services across new hampshire
we fully understand the budgetary
constraints that covert 19 has placed on
state revenues
and have worked hard to minimize the
impact on services
funding all positions is a priority for
the department and
we respectfully request a consideration
be given to do so
if additional revenues become available
during this phase of the budget process
director lavoy will now spend some time
discussing the important public safety
mission
of each of our seven divisions and
provide a summary of changes
current funding gaps and the expected
impact on service
we're happy to take any questions that
you may have throughout the presentation
and i greatly appreciate the interest
you have in the department of safety
thank you and uh i'd like to introduce
if that's okay representative umberga
director steve lavoie
that's fine go ahead steve all right
hi um good afternoon everybody madam
chair members of the committee steve
lavoy i'm the director of administration
at the department of safety
it's nice to see many of you again as we
go through our budget process and for
those who i haven't met
um i look forward to working with you
through this phase of the budget
can everyone see the presentation screen
okay
yes good yes yeah all right um so
what we've tried to do here is
consolidate 150 pages
of budget documents which includes 146
accounting units
into a a presentation that's digestible
and understandable for you
so hopefully we hit the mark there but
there's a lot going on at the department
of safety
and i think by the end of this
presentation you'll have a good
understanding about
what we do what's funded and then also
where some of our funding concerns are
the first page here is the
organizational summary of the department
as a whole
so we have seven divisions within the
department of safety
who are all committed to our mission of
continually enhancing the safety
security and the quality of life in new
hampshire
through professional collaborative and
innovative service to all
in each one of these divisions um you've
got the activity number that's listed
here the division of administration is
division of motor vehicles 2330 and so
on and so forth so those numbers
correspond with um
our activity numbers within the budget
uh and so this presentation is built to
follow
the budget structure as well um and so
you'll
you'll see that we'll go in order uh
according to these
organizations here so to start off
um our overall budget for the department
of safety our summary pages
is shown here what you'll notice as we
work through the presentation
uh each division we're going to be
summarizing in total
and providing the pages that correspond
to the governor's budget
in the upper right hand corner here but
for
fy 22 and 23 the department of safety
governor's
recommended budget is 203.5 million
dollars in fy 22
which represents a 5 increase over the
fy
20 amount 21 amounts and 209.3 million
dollars in fy 23 which is a 33
increase over the fy 22 amount
what you'll see over here is that the
department of safety is really a people
driven
organization we provide services to the
public
and so 63 of our budget is tied up in
salaries and benefits
the additional operating costs are a
combination of costs associated with
providing those services like equipment
abilities utilities but there's there's
also a large amount of grant funding
that we
distribute to uh municipalities to
locals
other state agencies so each division
will work through a similar format like
this to really try and summarize what's
going
on with our increase we mentioned um
that there's a um a five percent
increase year over year
overall at the department level 649
000 of that increase is due to
increases in salary and benefit costs
that amount would be significantly
higher
uh if it weren't for the 50 unfunded
positions
that the commissioner mentioned so we do
have 3.7
million dollars in salary and benefits
savings from 50 unfunded positions
in fy 23 we do have a six million dollar
increase
and that's because of increases in
salaries and wages we've got annual
increments which will come due
we also have a 27th pay period so i'm
sure you've heard about that from other
um other departments so far but there is
an extra pay in fy 23
which is going to move our costs up for
salaries and benefits
there is a 9.3 million dollar increase
in fy 22
that's primarily due to increases in
expected federal fund expenditures
so those might be funding from covid
related disaster funds from fema
additional
federal funds that you know in the past
maybe we haven't done a great job
estimating
um for example we didn't used to include
declared disasters within our budget
requests
but through work with the fiscal
committee it was determined we want to
include as many requests as we can
based on good estimates that we have so
we've included those in here and that's
a large part of the increase
the total general highway and turnpike
uh
and cost of collections funding for the
department uh has decreased year over
year so we've got an 8.3 million dollar
decrease
and as the commissioner mentioned that's
a 7.1 decline in general funds
9.7 in turnpike 11.5
in in costa collections which is also
highway funds
i'll talk a little bit about that
distinction in a minute
just as a refresher for everyone but
we do have an increase in our other
funding sources though
of 6.5 million in fy 22
and 1.7 million in fy 23.
and that's due in large part to what the
commissioner had mentioned
where we were shifting costs to our
dedicated funds
allocating those costs where where they
truly should have always been paid in
prior years
um but we were really forced to take a
hard look at our our allocation process
because of those um the weaknesses
within the general and highway and
turnpike funds
and we were able to we were successfully
able to move some funding
into those dedicated funds appropriately
to reduce our draw in those areas and
that's how we're able to maintain
all of our public safety services even
though we have a significant decline in
general
highway turnpike cost of collections
funds
if you look at the chart up here you'll
see we've got color coding for each fund
source
many of our divisions are mixed funded
as the department is as a whole we've
tried to carry the colors forward
through each division
so as an example if we look at the 22
budget here
this is for the department as a whole
where the budget
funds the department with 44.6 million
dollars in general funds
which makes up 22 of the total 203.5
million
so then highway funds 34.3 cost of
collections
30.3 cost of collections as a reminder
to everybody
as established and i got to look at my
reference here article 6a of the
constitution and then rsa99
a the any costs associated with the
collection and administration of highway
funds
by the department of safety shall be
deducted before being credited to the
highway fund
so what that means is essentially the
the um costs associated with the dmv
because the dmv collects uh all their
fees that they collect end up going into
the highway fund is revenue
so the cost of the dmv and also the
costs of
the road toll bureau who collects the
state gas tax
those costs are taken off before the
money that they collect
and hits the highway fund the best way
to think of this is actually as if
cost of collections equals highway funds
from a budget perspective
but we're required to appropriate and
report this way and so we continue to do
so
but that's an important distinction we
do we do loop
those in together because they both have
the same impact on the highway fund
which is reducing
reducing the amount of revenues that are
available
so then purple is our turnpike color 8.6
million
and fy 22 which represents four percent
of the department's total
the other funds are 55.3 million
that's going to be all of our other
dedicated funds that includes the 911
fund
the fire fund watercraft safety
criminal records and several other
smaller funds
and then blue is federal 30.4 million or
15 percent of the total budget
so you'll see we tried to carry these
colors forward for consistency moving
forward
um but but there's definitely even just
visually you can see there's a reduction
in
our um our state i call them our
primary state fundings our general
highway and cost of collections
and turnpike fundings the last piece to
bring your attention to is the section
on the right here related to our
positions
within the governor's budget and the
budget documents there are 1135
classified
and 13 unclassified positions that are
authorized
within the budget there are 72
classified and one
unclassified positions that are unfunded
the commissioner mentioned that um you
know we have 50 positions
that are unfunded in uh 2223
up here you can see there's an
additional 23 positions that are
previously unfunded state police
positions
these are sworn positions troopers
um sergeants and the like that were not
funded for several biennium
so um they're included in this total
but they're not newly unfunded the 50
positions that we are speaking to
um for the rest of the presentation are
newly unfunded as in
they were funded in the 2021 biennium um
they were filled positions um there
might be some that are vacancies as well
and um those 50 are now not funded in
this in this position in this budget
request
all right so if we move on to our first
area is the office of the commissioner
so the office of the commissioner um it
consists of the commissioner and two
assistant commissioners
all seven divisions report directly to
the commissioner
and the department's public information
officer
the office of highway safety the legal
unit and the bureau
of hearings are all organized within the
um
within the office of the commissioner
the office of highway safety
they develop and implement our statewide
highway safety program
and it's really designed to reduce
traffic crashes
and obviously reduce any resulting death
or injury
and also property damage they administer
federally funded safety grant programs
uh they plan and they
implement all the federal funded highway
safety projects across the state
there's a lot of money that they award
to locals for increased enforcement
activities
and local pds and also some
public relations activities to encourage
the
public to to buckle up because we do not
have a safety belt law in new hampshire
but we do want to encourage people to
wear a safety belt whenever they can
the legal unit is responsible for
providing legal services to the entire
department
and all the divisions in all of our
programs
their duties include advising management
on legal issues related to policies and
procedures
they handle administrative rule making
operations personnel issues
labor management issues they're also
available for assistance with contract
reviews
civil liability and right to know
requests and any other issues
as needed the bureau of hearings
is responsible for conducting
administrative hearings criminal
prosecution
in select circuit courts litigation of
hearings appeals and also
hearings of the new hampshire motor
vehicle industry board
they also prosecute most of the state
police dwi cases throughout the state
the view of a unit of prosecutory
attorneys
as you can see here what we'll do
throughout is list where our unfunded
positions are
in the structure and so in the office of
the commissioner there's one unfunded
position in the high
office of highway safety and two
unfunded positions
in the bureau of hearings steve
yes with these uh positions that you're
identifying
as unfunded could you tell us if these
are
as you're going through the briefing uh
part of the 50 new ones
or if those were there before
sure so i think the only positions that
will
that are identified uh in the
presentation are part of the 50.
so the 23 the state police 23 that i
mentioned at the beginning
are not included in the rest of the
presentation so it's only 50 the other
thank you for the clarification
appreciate it
sure so the next page we move on to the
office of the commissioner's budget
request page
the governor's recommended budget
requests
20.2 million dollars in fy 22 which is a
increase over fy21 and a 20.4 million
dollar increase in fy 23
which is a one percent increase over fy
22.
the 151 thousand dollar decrease in fy
is uh due to reductions in salary and
benefits from three unfunded positions
uh that decrease is offset by a 292
000 increase i'm sorry by a 1.2 million
dollar increase in fy 22
due to the combined impact of retiree
health expense
that got transferred out to the division
of state police and then increases in
federal grants and debt service payments
you can see from the funding perspective
here as far as in the blue
we do have an increase in our our
projected federal expenditures
from 8.2 to 12.4 million that's really
driving this increase
year over year in fy23 we do have a 292
thousand dollar increase
uh that again is going to be due to
salary and benefit increases from
increments and then also the 27th pay
period
within the office of the commissioner
there are a few
new positions that are funded within
this budget
there are two new 100 federally funded
positions within the office of highway
safety it's a field representative and
an informational representative too
those are both 100 federally funded and
intended to help them achieve their
mission of improving
highway safety uh and also helping to
move money
out of that area into uh the different
locals as needed
and then we also have funding for a new
attorney three to oversee investigations
in coordination with the attorney
general's office so these would be
department level investigations
and that's something that that was a gap
that needed to be filled that
we work closely with the attorney's
general's office on determining the best
approach and it was determined in
attorney 3
here at safety would be would be the
preferred option
we do have 45 authorized full-time
positions
that are classified and three
unclassified within the office of the
commissioner
and then in this area there are three
unfunded
full-time classified positions as well
and those positions will result result
in some delays in scheduling
and possibly some delays in grant and
contract processing to local state
agencies
on the next page this is the list of
funding gaps within the office of the
commissioner so if additional revenue
becomes available at this stage in the
process we would seek to fund
the existing bureau of hearings
positions that's an attorney for and
a secretary too and these positions
are used to schedule and conduct
adjudicative hearings
they have if they're not filled there
will be
delays in scheduling increased caseloads
for
the remaining examiners and there would
be delays also in the final report
issuance as as case loads just continued
to increase
there would also be an increased risk of
not meeting statutory deadlines for
certain
cases including administrative license
suspensions
we're not saying that would happen but
just the reality is with less staff
there's an increased risk and we do our
best to shift our resources
to make sure that we're meeting those
requirements first and foremost
and then the office of highway safety
position is a
program assistant two and this position
is
used to process contract and grant
documents with vendors and locals
this is distributing that federal aid at
the highway safety aid across the state
we have to reassign those
responsibilities to other people within
the office of highway safety
but again we've got people who are fully
tasked with other duties
it would likely result in delays and
could decrease the effectiveness of the
funding if
it takes us an extra month or two to
make a grant award that's a month or two
that the local may not be able to
utilize those funds
and that could increase the risk of
highway safety
vehicle issues steve yes
are these uh general funded
or highway-funded positions or whatever
yeah these are these are a mix um
so the bureau of hearings is um
is our highway funded positions the
highway safety position is partially
highway funded and partially
what do i want to say because of the mix
of funding
each each of these positions would have
to
um like
some would have to come from highway
someone would have to come from
someplace
else um well
yes and no so the
we can we could change the funding mix
um depending upon the source of funds
that were available
so if general funds were available we
can always add general funds to any area
because they're general funds
if there were highway funds that's where
we have less flexibility because now we
have to make sure we meet the
requirement
of to spend those funds because they are
restricted so
um so to your point if there were
highway funds available or turnpike
funds
we would have to be careful about where
we use those but if there were general
funds
we would be able to utilize all of those
thank you steve can i just add one point
sure yeah so i just wanted to just for
clarification if you look so we're
looking to add an attorney
and as you can see we're trying to um
get an attorney
for which would be actually the number
two in the bureau hearings funded if
possible
and completely separate um
duties of responsibilities why we wanted
to
why i need to add an attorney three to
our in-house legal counsel is
the complexity of our internal affairs
and to ensure we have
a person managing them many of these
sometimes are personnel violations some
could border on criminal
some can be walled off so you have to
have
essentially two cases going at once the
criminal side and the personnel side
some of our investigations could involve
other agencies so what we found was
um to ensure that we're managing it and
we have transparency in it so we don't
have one person
making a decision there'd be you know
more broader oversight
that's why based on the duties and
responsibilities they have in there now
with personnel with litigation with
contracts with 91as we were falling um
we weren't in a position of managing to
success and
and with the leak uh commission you know
i found that
that we definitely need more oversight
and we need
a greater uh overall management of these
investigations and so that's that that
is
what that position is about i had many
conversations with
you know the attorney general's office
okay so moving on to um our first
division which
uh again um it's based off the budget
numbers
um but this is my favorite division
because it happens to be the one that
i'm the director of
the vision of administration provides
internal support services to all the
divisions in safety
and our mission is to provide the
highest quality support services in all
of the areas that we
oversee each bureau we're made up of six
different bureaus and each has a direct
impact
on the unique public safety mission
within
all of the department of safety and we
really view
ourselves as a force multiplier trying
to minimize the administrative burden so
the divisions can focus
um as much as possible just on mission
delivery
um our our vision is that we're a
recognized partner and a valuable asset
to
all the divisions in helping them run
their business
so we have six bureaus the financial
management and planning bureau
manages all the finances for the
department including the
coordination and the development of the
operating and the capital budget
this is your typical accounts payable
accounts receivable
purchasing contracts all the fiscal
related items
um gnc items those types of things
the human resources management bureau
provides hr
functions to all employees and divisions
within the department
we've got the payroll function under
human resources this also includes
hiring under talent acquisition our
organizational management area which
works on reclassification of positions
when necessary when business needs
change
and then also performance management for
employee evaluations
and and discipline as needed and risk
management which is our
workers compensation family medical
leave
all those those challenging leave
requests that employees have over time
the asset and resource management bureau
maintains all of our fixed and mobile
assets
they are also responsible for
warehousing all of our supplies
and inventorying all of our fixed assets
they
they ship items to the divisions across
the state
and they also run an automotive garage
where they perform repair on their fleet
primarily our state police vehicles but
all of our fleet vehicles just state
police is the largest customer
we also have a mail room and the mail
room is extremely busy
they process about 1.8 million pieces of
incoming mail
about 1.6 pieces of outgoing mail a lot
of that has to do with dmv
notifications license renewals um things
of that nature
so you can imagine that's important that
that that mail continues to be moving
efficiently and then lastly we also are
responsible for
the the plate room so we distribute over
500 000 license plates to municipal
agents uh
and the dmv substations across the state
the
road toll bureau the road tow bureau
collects the state's road toll
also known as the gas tax um and that
supports the highway fund
so road toll collections each year are
about
188 million um 130 million of that
is unrestricted highway funds and
another
58 million of that is restricted to
certain purposes
um over at dot so there are funds used
to pay down debt
betterment funds those types of things
we also have an audit function in road
toll
and that function it's not
purely designed just to find additional
revenues it's really designed to
encourage voluntary compliance
by taxpayers when taxpayers realize
there's an audit function
they're more likely to comply with uh
with the law
and so i think i think we have good
compliance in that area
we also have a grants management bureau
which is responsible for
administering and reporting federal
grants for the department
and specifically homeland security
grants that homeland security grant
program which distributes funds to both
locals and state agencies
and this bureau is extremely busy they
manage sub awards um
oftentimes over 400 sub awards at any
given time
to locals and state agencies and then
last but not least our facilities
management bureau
is responsible for the maintenance
construction groundskeeping
and also our energy efficiency projects
at 44
dos facilities so we have a
large facilities footprint across the
state
some of those facilities are our
administrative services facilities but
we work closely with them and our team
will will collaborate and help get
projects done as needed even in those
buildings that aren't
strictly dos funded and as you can see
we do have
several unfunded positions one of which
is the deputy director
so moving on to the division of
administration budget
steve yes yeah could you uh
send uh to us uh the
breakdown of what's funded
by das and what's funded by uh
dos so that we have a
understanding of that relationship sure
as far as which facilities
right yes sure
got it okay
so um the division administration the
governor's recommended budget for
2022 is 10.5 million dollars
which is a 32 decrease over fy21
and 10.9 million dollars in fy 23
which is a 1.1
increase over fy 22.
the one 1.2 million dollars of the
decrease
is due to salary and benefits from 14
unfunded positions within the division
the 3.7 million dollar decrease
of or 3.7 million of the decrease in fy
is due to um division specific operating
costs so doit operating costs were
changed we changed how we allocated
those within this budget
in the past the department of i'm sorry
the division of administration
uh for for whatever reason we we carried
the brunt of the
it costs and funded them with highway
funds
we uh instead allocated those out
using pc count as a primary allocation
when possible
to the different areas within the
department which helped to
reduce the draw and highway fund and
charge the dedicated funds appropriately
for the it services that they were
receiving
so that's a big chunk of of why there's
a decline here
um and then i'll
i'll show you appendix a in a minute
because this will come up several times
moving forward
there is a 325 000 increase in fy
23 and that's due to the increase in
salaries and benefits
from employee increments in the 27 pay
period
and then the impact of the unfunded
positions which we'll go into a little
bit more detail
is really just increasing in it'll
negatively impact
uh our ability as a division to deliver
support services to all the other
divisions
and will require them to to take up some
more of the administrative burden which
is really the
something that we don't want to do we
want them focused on on mission delivery
and then also some road toll positions
might negatively impact the highway fund
so you can see here we've got our 13
classified and one
and then this is the listing of our
funding gaps related to admin
so again if revenue became available we
would request
that these positions be funded the
deputy director
oops the deputy director of
administration
this is an unclassified position that
was established in
fy 2021 and that's to provide additional
support services to
all the other divisions uh that role is
really critical in helping us to
implement the process and
reporting improvements that we'd like to
implement
to again minimize the administrative
burden that the divisions currently have
while keeping them engaged and involved
in the budget process
and contracting and all those services
there are three hr positions that are
unfunded and these will will
cause cause some problems because we'll
have to reassign
some significant duties to existing
staff who are already
um already have a full load um
specifically the risk as we call it the
risk management area so
family medical leave act workers
compensation americans with disabilities
act
any of those accommodation requests that
employees make
those have to be processed there's a
little bit of a legal component to it it
definitely requires
timeliness as well we really need a
full-time position for that but for the
time being
those roles are being completed by other
people within that area
and we'd have to continue to do that
moving forward if this position
financial management and planning we've
got accounting technician and
administrative assistant
and these positions are really critical
to the timely and accurate processing of
all of our vendor payments
also working through our fiscal note
development and tracking for the
legislature so that's all
managed centrally within this area and
these individuals
ensure that that occurs timely and
accurately
and then finally we've got our
procurement activities which fall under
these areas as well and so there'd
likely be delays and procurement
across the board um and again pushing
that down to the other
oh that's okay um i just
uh in the uh areas where you have
several unfunded positions
would you mind uh providing us with
a uh this is my top priority this is
second this is third
i mean i really i realize they're all
important but
more than likely uh there's no way that
they're all going to get funded
and so um out of your
50 unfunded positions uh
it would be nice if we could have some
sort of a
priority list for um
you know to look at and
i i believe uh representative heath
also has a question oh thank you madam
chair this is
um just listening to the number of
positions that you're eliminating
it sounds like it's really going to
impact a variety of things i mean when i
hear
issues with procurement um
completing fiscal notes what about
services
that that are necessary um
i guess my first question is number one
um how much
money did you um lapse um
in the past year and secondly isn't
there some way
to really
mitigate funds without impeding
sure so so we're projecting to labs
approximately four million dollars in
general funds
um this year another two
uh two and a half million in highway
funds
another two million in costa collections
um so uh we've also we're also lapsing
just under a million and about a million
in uh
turnpike funds so uh there's a
significant amount of funding that that
we've
we've been forced to lapse this year um
and that if if you recall that that was
really due to the unknown
nature of the revenue sources so we had
a hiring freeze and
we've been working under those reduced
numbers for for some time
um and and uh you know i i just
i want to take a minute too and just let
you know that the
staff at all divisions in the department
of safety they've done a tremendous job
because we've all been impacted by this
and they've really remained positive and
continue to get the job done
so um i think
it's important for this committee to
understand what the impacts are
and and we're doing this i don't want to
be um
we don't want to be um saying that
there's a crisis
mode going on but just to be clear that
these are the areas that would be
impacted
and we'll have to shift resources we
still will be able to get the job done
and so that's important to understand
we're going to be able to get it done it
just
it's going to take us longer and if it
takes us longer it might increase the
risk
associated with not getting things done
more timely within those different
areas so i think you'll see that we've
spread these out
over multiple different areas without
having a large hit in one single area
and that's one of the goals that we made
representative petra you have a question
yes madam chair thank you and thank you
for taking my question i understand
there's a significant backlog in
background checks
and uh i guess it's over a month in some
situations could you address that please
i'll take that um sir which background
checks are you referring to
uh when when people purchase a firearm
i guess that runs through your
department and uh
on on to the federal uh level uh
sure sure yeah so there's actually
that's the permits and licensing unit
which
representative umbarger had a uh had a
detailed explanation on that a few years
ago and helped us with our funding but
um
so in the permits and licensing sir they
do uh the approvals for a new
purchase of a handgun so if you went in
to purchase a handgun
uh the ffl would uh communicate to the
permits and licensing unit
um i would say over the last six
i would say six to eight weeks we have
really redefined our business model down
there
and now our uh our turnaround time
is uh i would say very good they've got
some
they're handling the calls one at a time
and the backlog there on our
approvals is i mean they're handling
many i can look
i get a weekly dashboard within a half
hour so
the other area down there where we get
questioned on is
out of state permits so that's an area
we have to monitor
return authorization to the courts on
firearms that have been taken
by the court through a process um ex
parte and then
the court requires us to do a check to
see if the weapon can
be turned back and then the backlog on
those were that were delayed
so if a customer goes to us
to a to an ffl uh shop to purchase a
weapon
we can either tell him or her that it is
approved
and on approval we're getting those many
of those done within 30 minutes denied
which can be rather quick if there's you
know a clear
disqualifying offense or delayed and the
delay
means there is something that has come
up on the criminal history
that is not conclusive and it requires
us to do some research
so we had been behind in the delays
um the returns to the court but we've uh
turned many of those around greatly
within the last
four four weeks and i can get you more
information
um um offline but um i would say they're
doing uh
significantly better today than we were
in the last two months so we we we have
a team
we've added uh we've got a state police
major that's overseeing it with the
colonel so
yes we did have significant backlogs but
we've reduced many of those
thank you very much sir thank you and if
i could add to that
representative p3 we actually have
later in the presentation you'll see
we've added three positions to that
area in this budget which will further
help us to address those
those concerns representative lynn you
excuse me it's more it's more of a
comment than a question i i have to say
a representative petri just uh
for your information my one of my best
friends is an
ffl uh that lives in fremont and i just
happen i see him
you know at least twice a week and just
recently we had a conversation in which
he was telling me that
um although there had been some you know
some delay in getting the ffl
getting the checks done that had
improved significantly
in the last couple of months or so so he
thank you
great so um the
four existing asset and resource
management bureau positions
um these are really key roles in that
area to help
continue providing supplies to the other
divisions so the automotive shop manager
too
which oversees the garage the forms
design and control clerk to make sure
that all of our forms
are up to date and they're accurate
they're tied back to our administrative
rules stock clerk and mail clerk again
keep the product moving keep those
things moving those those are critical
in the road toll bureau we have three
road toll auditor twos
and a counter clerk that are unfunded
and as i mentioned the audit function is
important we do collect over 188 million
in revenues in that area and the audit
function
does help to encourage voluntary
compliance with taxpayers
it's unlikely that we'd be able to
complete the same number of audits as we
currently do
now there are some requirements for
audits within certain programs that we
have to meet a
criteria on we would focus our resources
on meeting those
would go undone and then the
facility maintenance costs we've
historically underfunded our facility
maintenance costs for the department
of safety last budget was the first time
we were able to add additional funding
but then covet hit and we couldn't move
forward with any of the projects
or very few of the projects that we had
intended and then the spending freeze uh
made that even worse so
there is additional funding that if
money was available that we would
request to help us maintain our
facilities across the state
representative heath you have a question
i do thank you very much
madam chair um it's just a brief
question would it be possible um
for you to do a breakdown of
uh general funded positions federal
funded positions
buy bureaus i guess or divisions that
you have
for us um in totals
where you're deleting those where where
the numbers are being reduced so that we
just kind of have kind of like a chart
that would be very good thank you okay
so total
total uh total positions by division
um what's funded what's unfunded
source of funding for them and the
funding source yeah
okay we can do that yep and and split
funded steve correct
yeah right yeah the vast majority are
going to be funded so we'll show that
impact
all right yeah and so that's that split
will
include general other and highway
and turnpike and turnpike and we'll show
we'll show cost of collections where
wherever it's appropriate
okay on to sorry we're giving you so
many things to do
steve but hey i i love it it's it's i
enjoy doing
this stuff so go ahead and throw it at
me okay
thank you um the division of motor
vehicles
um the division of motor vehicles uh the
mission is to enhance public safety on
the roadways
in new hampshire by ensuring that really
everyone's properly credentialed
whether that's drivers vehicles service
providers
and also making sure that we've got
exceptional and efficient customer
service in the areas of licensing motor
vehicles
and motor vehicle related matters and
the division is broken
up into five bureaus and then also an
administration unit
the bureau of driver licensing is
responsible for issuing driver licenses
but also non-driver ids the driver
licenses
they issue operator licenses commercial
driver licenses
real ids and part of that process of
issuance might include
a vision test or a knowledge test or
road test for people getting their
license for the first time
that's all handled by the by this bureau
they have automated touchscreen testing
system
that is implemented and the licensing
bureau also
provides training for new and
experienced uh motorcycle riders through
a motorcycle rider training program
each year they produce over 350 000
licenses
they perform about 27 000 skills and
road tests
so that that's a big area for the dmv
the bureau of financial responsibility
this is the area that maintains the
driving records
individual driving history the status of
their license
vehicle registration privileges it's
really the repository for
data gathered from all the law
enforcement agencies and circuit courts
and district courts
and also out out-of-state motor vehicle
agencies and so the bureau
receives and processes records that come
in from these different sources
they update individuals uh driving
records and that
would include changes in to document
convictions or suspensions and
revocations
and also restoration dates and and if
there were any crashes or accidents that
they were involved in
this is also the area that collects the
um plea by mail
tickets so when a violation is issued
individual has the option to plea by
mail with a payment to the dmv
those get processed here if they'd like
to contest their ticket that's when the
ticket then moves to the court system
instead
the bureau of operations is responsible
for
overseeing all the daily customer
interactions whether that's in person or
over the phone or through email
they uh they operate 13 substations
as well as the concord dmv location
and they've done really focused on
customer service and trying to
cross-train their staff
so that they can conduct any type of
motor vehicle transaction that the
customer needs
at any given time and so they've been
very successful
in doing that uh just as an idea in
typical
pre-covet times there were over 20 000
calls each month
um that number's definitely increased
because we're now
moving into an appointment based system
um but
that's another area that i just want to
take a take a brief minute to
let the committee know so director
galecki elizabeth bolecki is the
director of
motor vehicles she's really done a great
job in keeping the dmv
open and functioning during covid so a
lot of other states
um you know they decided to shut down
dmv
functions for a period of time we didn't
in
in new hampshire so the dmv was closed
for two days while they shifted to an
appointment based system as opposed to
just walk-ins
and we've invested in technology the
governor's office
helped us with with some gopher funding
to do so and made some changes to the
dmv process so now
um dmv remained open albeit there were
delays
i'm not going to say there weren't
delays we had less staff we couldn't
schedule as many appointments
but at least you know you knew when you
were coming into the dmv you knew you
had
a block of time you could schedule your
day accordingly
um and and i think that from what we
hear
the public's really pleased with the new
appointment based process so
um dmv fundamentally changed how they
did business during
uh covid and and i think that they they
have some benefits that came from that
as well
uh bureau of registrations um so they
oversee registrations of vehicles
uh it's really vehicles trailers or
boats uh essentially anything except for
ohrvs off highway recreational vehicles
and and they don't deal with the
snowmobiles either but the purpose is to
protect the public really in this
function
so if there's a collision or a theft or
a violation of law
they can identify the vehicle and
that's an important part of of operating
a vehicle safely in the state
we have a municipal agent automation
project that's our map system maap
and this connects about 230 municipal
agents
to the dmv and so that's how the
municipal agents are able to
issue plates and process dmv
transactions at the local level
for for their for their residents um
they process about 1.5 million
registrations each year
the bureau of title and anti-theft
that area processes all new and
duplicate titles
applications for motor vehicles and
trailers
they they enter the information for all
vehicles sold through state
authorized dealerships refinanced
vehicles and salvaged vehicles
and they're all always reviewing those
um title applications for fraud as well
that's something we want to make sure
that we stay on top of and
this is an important function because
the the new hampshire automobile dealers
really depend on
timely processing of these titles so
they can offer trade-in vehicles for
sale
soon after purchase we issue about 300
333 000 titles each year and then
there's an administration section that
manages dmd contracts procurements and
audit functions
for the division and you can see where
the unfunded positions are are located
within dmv
um so here we have our budget request
governor's recommended budget for the
dmv for
fy 22 is a total of 28.1 million dollars
which is a 7.6 decrease from 21
and it's a 29.1 million dollar request
in 23 which is a 3.3 percent increase
uh over 22 96
i'm sorry 963 000 of the 22 decrease
are due to decreases in salaries and
benefits from 16 unfunded
positions and also 150 000
decrease in part-time funding um that
that was made
again to meet the revenues that were
available
1.3 million of the fy 22 decrease
is due to a decrease in operating costs
including doit
expenses debt service and facility
maintenance costs
in fy 23 832 000
of the increase is due to increases in
salaries and benefits from
increments and then that 27th pay period
again with similar to admin we have
significant reductions in
full-time and part-time staffing levels
all services will still be produced and
provided but there will likely be delays
in certain areas
and dmv is going to continue to work on
moving things online
and processing transactions efficiently
and fully leverage technology so that
they can continue to improve customer
service even without
these um staffing uh resources that
we've had in the past
steve can i um shouldn't i add just one
thing
before we leave dmv i just want to say i
want to
just emphasize a little when colbert uh
struck on or about march 3rd march 10th
we opened the aoc
between then and uh and currently
director belicky has continued to finish
projects
to get services online
everything that can be done online she's
migrating that way she's done a
tremendous job
we had a comparison to our dmv to the
other new england states and i would be
proud to say that i think we are
you know leading them all with not only
the emphasis on customer service and
lines but
there's a tremendous impact on public
safety there as steve said with the
financial responsibility
um uh our interlock program you know
ensuring
um things uh travel to hearings as they
should be
but i just think it's important to note
that not only have we
stayed open and we've she's kind of
managed and been
very very uh nimble through kobit
they've finished projects and i think
you know the future looks
looks very bright so anything we can get
done online and then that allows us to
shift
people um that we're required to do it
but the qmatic scheduling system has
really
been a game changer for the dmv now
folks are not waiting in line
and uh so i think that i think um uh
thank you for the continued support of
the dmv and i think we're being very
very responsible with these dollars and
ensuring that
the public benefits not only in customer
service but on the safety piece
thank you yes and i would like to
thank director balecki in particular for
making sure that all the legislators
legislators
could get their get their plates as
they as they needed them so
yeah that was uh that was very nice uh
representative petry you have a question
yes i do madam chair um
the um actually i got a comment uh you
did an excellent job in uh
delivering the ppe i know uh the
beginning uh when we were escorted by
state troopers that was interesting
and then the model changed to bringing
the ppe to
dmvs has that incurred an additional
cost
to the to the department or you just do
it in stride
i can i can address that commissioner um
so obviously whenever there's staffing
uh involved there's the salary and
benefits that are attached to them
uh but there's no additional costs
necessarily besides the time
the cost it is to take someone to manage
that program
all of those ppe and the distribution
systems
all that's getting reimbursed with
federal monies uh
and so anything that we have been
spending will will get recouped over
time
thank you uh representative murray you
have a question
yes thank you again uh this i may have
done a fabulous job and this move to
online is that a permanent
move will you continue to do all the
stuff that you're doing now online
post coven i'm looking is there a silver
lining here that some things may
actually
pertain going forward to some advantage
to us um
yeah i'll start and steve can back
cleanup yeah we're not going backwards
so everything that we've migrated online
is going to stay online
and i think what would be helpful is
maybe uh the director can forward uh
representative umber we've got a nice
chart of what we've done
and what the next projects are in the
queue so we've gotta
we've got a few more that um she's
trying to get done
but um yeah oh no these will be these
will be permanent absolutely
yeah and i give i give her credit the
governor uh
office on the capital investments but i
think that you know with everybody's
benefited from the
uh the dollars and uh and again it's a
credit to uh the director
you know she's done a nice job getting
these projects completed
yeah that would be very helpful
commissioner if uh if she could send
that
yeah okay and i'll include that
with our other requests for you
okay uh you're back on steve
okay thank you
um so now we look at the
16 unfunded positions in dmv
and again you're going to see a theme
here where there's going to be delays to
service so the first
group there's two positions in driver
licensing
these positions are required to schedule
driver license examinations and conduct
them
and they've needed to offer road tests
in all locations
to prevent customers from having to
travel too far for those critical
services
so without all a full complement of
driver licensing
examiners we can't offer driver license
exams at every dmv
substation across the state
in the registration bureau there are
five
full-time unfunded positions uh
and those are required to prevent delays
in the assistance that is provided to
town clerks
while they're processing those map
transactions those registrations
boat renewals dealer inspection station
applications
also vanity plates and walking
disability placards so
those are all the general registration
functions that occur
and these positions would negatively
impact
all of those areas in the title bureau
there's two positions
an examiner and a supervisor three and
those are required to prevent delays in
processing the title documents
and as i mentioned before this is an
area that the new hampshire automobile
dealers are really
focused on making sure we continue
timely processing
in financial responsibility um
these are this is the area where your
driving history record is updated
and so any violations or accidents need
to be timely processed
um so that your record is up to date and
many of these transactions result in
suspensions and revocation of privileges
and so we want to make sure that those
are updated and reversed in a timely
manner
as well in operations
um there's four positions there and
these are those direct service positions
at all the substations
they conduct the counter transactions
where even though we're moving more and
more online um
we still have a need for in-person
transactions and so
the less people we have the less uh
scheduled times we can
we can fill um
and then finally part-time employees in
operation so
the dmv relies very heavily on part-time
employees
that's how they shift uh and cover when
full-time folks are unavailable do the
annual leave or illness
and so part-time would really helped to
fill us a need for us
and also when there's search support
needed so if there's an increase in
volume
uh we rely on our part-timers and
additional funding we did reduce the
part-time budget
we would look to to return that to
the levels that are required if funding
was available
there's also a new position request that
was important
that i wanted to mention that's the
program assisted two and that's an
area in the um ignition interlock
program at dmv and so this person would
be responsible for the oversight of
those violations hearings
and management of that program for any
drivers who
were convicted of alcohol related
convictions and moved into that program
and then again facility maintenance
costs because of our different funding
sources
because cost of collections supports dmv
we
um we budget for facility maintenance
costs for dmv locations within the dmv
so much like an admin where we have
facility maintenance for the other dos
facilities
here an additional 20 000 would be
requested for the dmv
facilities
okay moving on the next division
yeah just a second a second
they so the cost of collections is
pretty much
funded by the um
[Music]
funded by the um highway
and turnpike is that correct just the
highway
just the highway okay so cost
collections is funded by the highway
and so any changes in this area
would impact the highway fund
is that correct any changes would impact
the highway fund
yes okay but let me give you an example
of some of the things that
some of the funding decisions our
ability that we have
if if we typically treat cost of
collections
and highway funds as interchangeable so
if additional general funds become
available
those general funds could replace
highway funds within
the department within the division of
state police or highway funds within the
commissioner's office
which would reduce the highway fund draw
and allow us to increase the cost of
collections by the same amount
so we have some flexibility if general
funds become available
to shift our funding sources uh around
um so next is our largest division the
division of state police
uh the division of state police is our
statewide law enforcement agency
and they enforce state criminal motor
vehicle and other public safety laws
across the state they have concurrent
jurisdiction in towns with the
population level under 3 000
and primary jurisdiction on all
interstate highways and they operate
seven troop stations a marine patrol
facility
aircraft hangar they also operate the
state forensic lab
criminal records unit permits and
licensing unit as you can see
lots of different pieces here i'm not
going to go into a lot of detail in each
one but i want to spend a little bit of
time
describing what some of these key
functions are
so under the operations bureau they're
the primary
motor vehicle enforcement and criminal
deterrence patrol
uh statewide uh and as i mentioned for
communities that don't have their own
police force whether it's
because of cost concerns or just um or
funding issues or size the troopers
provide the whole range of law
enforcement
services in those areas taking
conducting controls taking calls for
service covering accidents investigating
criminal activity
so the state police are split up into
several troop stations um six troop
stations across the state
that's troupe a and epping which covers
rockingham and stafford
stratford counties that's covering 90s
interstate 95 the term spaulding
turnpike and route 101
as well as route 125.
troop b in bedford they cover
hillsborough county and portion of
rockingham county that's attached to
interstate 93.
uh troop c and keane they cover sullivan
and cheshire counties
troop d in concord covers merrimack
county and then also covers
uh 93 from hooksett to ashland
and also they're responsible for all the
coverage on 89.
troop e is responsible for belknap and
carroll counties
and then troop f uh is responsible for
coasts and grafton counties
and troop f is actually the largest
geographic area
of um of any of the the primary troop
stations
that is with the exception of troop g
which troop g has a
statewide uh presence they are the
commercial
motor vehicle enforcement part of the
state police
so they implement state laws and federal
regulations for
transporting hazardous materials and
persons and
goods and commercial vehicles while
those vehicles are on the road
and they also handle the overweight
vehicle limits on roads and bridges
and then finally the civilian group is
under troop g
the automotive equipment inspectors and
they uh
they enforce laws and rules uh related
to
auto dealerships and automotive
inspection stations
uh throughout the state uh the marine
patrol
is another section they're charged by
statute
with enforcing voting laws and rules
and they also provide training for the
voting public and they also install
navigational things so buoys um
those types of things they uh patrol
approximately 975 public bodies of water
the jurisdiction includes any public
body of water that's
larger than 10 acres in size and they
also patrol the atlantic ocean
hampton harbor the great bay and also
the mobile enforcement team is a
specialized unit
whose mission is to detect and enforce
crimes and hazards on the roadways in
communities throughout new hampshire
and they've they work closely with local
agencies in conjunction with drug
enforcement units to combat
illegal narcotic distributions in their
communities
we also have a special services group
which
is really special services are
additional
specialties that troopers have in
addition to their day-to-day
requirements and so these are these are
specially trained personnel
and they include services such as our
canine unit
collision analysis and reconstruction
unit for
for automobile accidents there's drug
recognition experts
explosive disposal unit a special events
response
team and then also special weapons and
tactics team swat team
that's all within the operations bureau
then we also have the investigative
services side of the house
major crime unit is one of the areas
that many of you are probably familiar
with so the major crime unit
investigates all homicides throughout
the state
and they also assist in investigations
pertaining to any other manners of death
officer-involved shootings public
integrity
escapes from prison other violent felony
level offenses so
they'll provide support as needed there
the narcotics investigations unit
investigates all drug and vice-related
crimes
they have a staff of undercover
personnel and specialized equipment
and that includes controlled buys of
illegal drugs
including heroin fentanyl and
methamphetamines
and then the special investigations unit
they
are highly specialized area really
focused on cyber crimes
for the most part computer and cyber
threats and other specialized crimes
including financial
organized crime human trafficking
so very specific and uh detailed uh
stuff that they that they deal with then
the
other side of the investigative criminal
justice information area is the justice
information bureau
so this is the area that contains the
permits and licensing unit criminal
records
uh the communications unit
communications is
a centralized dispatch center we've got
staffing in two different locations one
of which is in the uh
the ipoc the incident planning and
operations center in concord
we also have a backup location in true
beth which is located in twin mountain
and these staff they they dispatch
for all state police all troops they
dispatch for
liquor enforcement the state fire
marshal
department of natural and cultural
resources and also
fish and game and that's uh the fish and
game pieces
is a is a new change that's occurred
within this budget as well
as far as dispatching full time from
fish and game we've always dispatched
part-time
but now that's going to be a full-time
dispatching function
the the j-1 area that's the
one network environment for justice it's
a
it's a it's a system that allows
us to capture criminal justice
information at the source
and then transfer that to interested
parties
so it's transferring information from
police to dmv to courts in
back and forth and all every which way
the goal is to reduce errors and reduce
duplicate data entry and really just
improve the overall function of
of the criminal justice system in the
state
and there's certain functions that have
been moving to an online component
over time like e-tickets e-complaints
e-citations
and also live span fingerprint taking
electronically through the live scan
live scan machines
the criminal records unit falls under
this area they maintain the criminal
history record information
the which is the repository
they also manage the afis system the
automated fingerprint identification
system
and ucr the uniform crime reporting
permits and licensing which um they
operate the gun line as we mentioned the
commissioner mentioned earlier
where federal firearm license dealers
ffls request
background checks for new hampshire
residents purchasing handguns
commercially
they also do backgrounds on individuals
applying for non-resident concealed
pistol
licenses they also license armed and
unarmed pis private investigators
security guards bail bondsmen
and also issue certificates for the use
so there's a lot going on in the
division of state police
there's definitely a sworn aspect with
law enforcement activities there's also
the civilian aspect with a lot of
justice information
uh pieces but it's all it all falls
under state policing purview
uh representative heath you have a
question yes i do thank you
that is that was unbelievable your
presentation excellent
um that division is certainly
clearly very significant now
as a result of the commission the lia
commission
all of those individuals are going to
require um
a degree of training based on the
recommendations that came out of the
committee
are you going to incur additional costs
as a result of that
yes yeah we will in fact i'll jump ahead
based on that question we do have um
increased training costs these are
estimates of course because we don't
know what the true cost will be but
whereas
we included this within the budget 131
000 each year
representative heath yeah
i just wanted to add to the colonel and
his uh staff
do a monthly update on lee act as you
know i believe it was
49 recommendations the government
governor
approved all of them and so we're
tracking you know
what we've done what are our deadlines
you know there are many in there for
training
community engagement uh integrating
you know professionals uh uh mental
wellness
with our tactical teams uh as well
obviously as our uh
our digital evidence collection project
which includes the uh
body cameras and the cruiser cameras but
it's a it's a global
digital collection of good
great thank you very much representative
lynn
yes ma'am sure thank you uh my question
was directed and i
i think i saw in your in your last slide
before the current one
that there are nine vacancies in the
forensic lab
and i'm just how many people in total
are in the forensic lab that seems like
it's a
um yeah i can give you a minute i can
tell you how many are are in total
that it it is a lot i mean that's not
nine vacancies there's nothing to um
that that's that that's a lot and
what what we would um
again the challenge ends up being
identifying those areas within the lab
that have a deadline
that there's a statutory deadline
there's a case pending there's something
that needs to happen within a period of
time
make prioritizing those activities
with the understanding that there will
be delays in other
in in other lab services that are
provided
let me see if i can if i can quickly
give you the
the position count i'll jump in
steve well steve's looking for uh judge
so as you know the lab
we've got three two major components the
crims side on the left
the toxicology side on the right and
they also do digital evidence they've
had a couple vacancies on the um
cyber the um computer crime area but
you know i know the colonel looks very
closely at the backlogs whether it's on
fingerprints or
but i know with with the marijuana
decrease of submissions to the lab it's
allowed them to
concentrate more on the you know the
narcotics of fentanyl and
methamphetamine
and um so the thing with the lab that we
have to pay attention to is the the
training time to get somebody in there
whether they're on the fingerprint side
of the house you know to get them to the
point or
ballistics the firearms comes to mind
because it takes a couple years really
to get trained up but
um but we're i know that number seems
high but
we're working very close to maintain um
you know we're meeting all the deadlines
for court
and uh and that's but but again
you're right it is a you know there's a
significant amount of vacancies there
steve do you have the total number yeah
so there's 31 total positions in the
forensic lab
there's 10 positions in the toxicology
lab
and then i'm looking for the urine codis
so so maybe what we can do steve offline
we'll get
we'll get the judge where those
positions are in the lab
which ones are on krem which ones are on
top
i just don't want to waste any more time
looking for it yeah no no that's fine
that's fine
and really i think you've really
answered my question i i was really
concerned about you know what
if it was having a significant impact on
on providing
you know evidence that was needed in
court or or you know that kind of thing
and it's like
it sounds like it sounds like you've
been able to handle it but
obviously things things would be better
if you had if you had the
you know at least some of those
positions filled that
sounds to me yeah we're clearly not
ready to take a victory lap because as
you know this past year has been tough
to measure against with covet as to
what's being submitted what isn't so
um but what we we worked very closely
with them
uh the toxicology side you know i had a
meeting this morning on highway safety
it's important for highway safety to get
the tax results for the fatal
so um so we look at the i'll just say
this
we look at the metrics the kpis in every
division
what what do you need to be doing and
are you meeting your demands so
i'll i will look at that and i will have
steve get a
a a small memo back to representative
bombardier on the lab
i i do thank you very much i do have a
question
i thought a couple three years ago that
we added
uh people to the toxicology
side because of all the problems with
fentanyl and meth and heroin and
now i see that crystal meth is
raising its ugly head here in new
hampshire so
we're not i hope we're not decreasing
the number of people
point point well taken
just steve you don't need to give it to
me now just okay
yes we're we're going to get back
together here and yep
next week we'll get you the breakdown so
you can see but the vast majority of
those are not in the toxicology lab it's
either one or two positions
i believe that i believe it's one but
i'll get you the we'll get the yeah
we'll talk about it next time very good
thank you
so the state police budget request the
governor's budget for fy 22
recommended budget is 96.5 million
dollars which is a 12.9
increase over 21 and 99.8 million
dollars
in fy 23 which is a 3.5 percent increase
over fy 22.
um the significant changes here have to
do
with um a 3.4 million dollar increase in
and a 3.3 million dollar increase in 23
due to salary and benefit
increases from expected employee
increments and then that 27th pay period
in fy 23.
this was partially offset by a 1.3
million
decrease in fy 22 and a 1.4 million
decrease in 23 from savings associated
with those 15
unfunded civilian positions as i
mentioned before there are 23
unfunded troopers um those are reflected
in the number 38 here
under the unfunded classified position
um but
we're only really speaking to the 15
unfunded positions
throughout the presentation and as far
as requesting funding
to to refund those 15 only
the 4.3 million dollar d increase in fy
22 it's due in large part on the
operating side
to doit costs that i mentioned in the
admin
division used to be there were
reallocated out to the appropriate areas
based on
which divisions used the doit services
so that really
increased the depart division of state
police's operating budget
um in fy 22 and 23
and then we also have a 1.6 million
dollar increase due to increased
operating costs
because the cost of doing business is
continuing to increase
vehicle costs have increased for
replacement cruisers
um also the costs that we started to
speak to about the
uh additional training related to lee
act
those things are are driving just an
overall increased cost of
law enforcement in the state
we also replaced 1.9 million dollars in
general funds
with 911 funds for these communications
function and that's due to the
weaknesses in general fund highway fund
and turnpike fund revenues
so we were able to eliminate that draw
on
the the general fund
so the lee act expenses this this slide
shows the new funding that's included
within the budget
so this funding uh includes uh funding
for body and cruiser cameras
for new hampshire state police it's
about a million dollars a year
well that that's what's included we're
not quite sure what the true cost will
be yet there is an rfp that's
out on the street and we may need to
request additional funds based on
where that that comes but our estimate
is it's going to be around the million
mark
that does include three positions as
well to manage the program
because what's important to understand
with body and cruiser cameras
is that this is a digital evidence
program we're going to be creating
new digital evidence streams we have to
treat them like evidence we have to
record them we have to index them we
have to be able to
redact information that that's not
applicable
when people request this information so
just putting a camera on everybody
isn't uh isn't really the right approach
we need to make sure we have the
infrastructure behind it to support the
program
um just add to that too this is to all
our digital evidence
every picture we have from fatal car
crashes from
crime scenes to a trooper making a car
stop and
taking a picture of a you know
contraband in a glove box and
how do we get it to headquarters how do
we store it how do we maintain it
how do we disseminate it how do we deal
with 91as
how do we have synergy with prosecution
with defense attorneys
and um again there's there's some
unknowns that we won't know until the
rfp comes back but we
we want to make sure we do it right
we're a little unique
in our rfp because take for example
uh the manchester police department
their cars come
in and out of one central location where
they have their data downloaded
they can do a hut swap we have troopers
working in remote areas where
they may not come to one central point
they may you know
maybe so we're looking at different
options so now we're looking at
somewhat of a you know an rfp on
wireless options so it's the
it's the downloading and storage which
is the real
um driver to this and uh i'm lucky to
have ac rick bailey
who's helping manage this project so
rick is very very uh
strong in in i.t and he's working very
closely with dennis goulet on this
will you be able to get us information
on storage i remember back in the day
when i was on criminal
one of the barriers to um to these sorts
of programs
had to do with not so much the cost of
the equipment but the cost of the
storage
and the years since has storage become
less
expensive and will we be able to get
some estimates around storage of what
you will need in order to do this going
forward
so we that is part of the um proposal so
we'll know that when the rfp comes back
so yes but to your point
representative bucco you have a question
yes uh yes i do thank you um
commissioner uh
i i thought in the last budget cycle we
approved uh
dash cams for all the cruisers has that
been carried out or what what's the
status of that program
no so so what happened was we had a
project in place that was looking
just at in cruiser cameras but now we've
added
in cruiser um and the body cameras so we
will have the best
system in place i think so we're going
to have uh
you know full 360 uh coverage
so so this is this is in addition to
what was what was previously approved
yes sir or that the dash cams that's
correct
but i just want to be clear with
everyone well they are not in now
so we are waiting for you know the
proposal back and we've got a timeline
as to when we hope to get them in plan
implemented you know into governor
council on this oh
okay that was my question i didn't know
what the status of the program was yeah
thank you
so the um the other lee act we talked
about increased trading costs the other
uh cost is related to medical and
psychological support
um contracts with professionals to
support the swat team
so those are very stressful situations
and one of the recommendations was that
we have those resources available to
those teams when they're
when they're out in the field so there
there's the sum of our of our lee act
components um permits and licensing unit
as i mentioned earlier we're funding
excuse me just a moment uh
i know that um police standards and
training
are going to be doing this
type of training are you working with
them
to make sure that it's included
in their training program that they're
going to be setting up
over the next couple years
that's a great question uh
representative and yes uh
director skipper was on the league
commission and we have had
lengthy conversations about you know
once we develop these modules
whether they're on uh unconscious bias
or use of force or you know
de-escalation
we're working together so that we can
share and leverage them
and um you know and so to use them
across the board and you know a lot of
this training has to get done at the
local level you know
everybody does not go to to police
stanza trainer to get it so
to your point we're trying to work
together to get
the most bang for our buck here on with
these modules
so the permits and licensing positions
we already spoke to those
marine patrol new positions we do have
two new marine patrol
officer two positions those are both 100
federally funded from the coast guard
grant and those are to meet demands for
services out on the seacoast
patrols out in hampton beach and also
cargo escorts that are required to be
done
um bringing cargo in required by
homeland security
uh and then last this isn't really
there's no funding necessarily
associated with this
but there is unification of state
dispatch services
so this budget formally unifies the
dispatching operations
between fish and game and state police i
i think i had mentioned earlier it was a
um
we were dispatching on a part-time basis
now this will be on a full-time basis
and what's key to understand here is
that this is the
emergency dispatch function only so
fish and game operate what they call
their law line
which the public can call up and ask
what do i do about
a certain um a certain wildlife issue if
um
you know if i have a how do i what do i
do with the bear that's in my backyard
those calls will still go to uh fish and
game those won't be routed through
through dispatch um the dispatch will be
for the emergency functions getting the
officers
out to respond to emergency events uh
out in the community
i just wanted to add to representative
if you look at those marine patrol two
full-time positions i think what's
important to add is they have struggled
um for years i say struggle it's a
challenge to recruit the part-timers
and the colonel actually did an analysis
of how much you can get
out of two full full time working 12
months a year
as opposed to a part-time marine patrol
officer so
they really did the metrics and numbers
on it and uh and it's incredible how
much more you can get
so i think it's a long-term benefit um
and and i know we we have the funding
for approximately 50 part-timers and we
struggle
um every year to maybe hit the 34 steve
maybe 35 part-time so i think this is uh
uh i think it's it's very wise uh
thank you so then moving on if more
funding becomes available
um to the committee these are the areas
and state police we would seek
additional funding for
um so obviously we've already spoken
about this but the the first
is uh funding within the lab for the
nine positions
in forensics codis and the talks lab um
as we mentioned these are uh really
required to meet demands for service
and if we don't have these positions
we'll be forced to um
really rely on on existing staff and
over time to meet any court deadlines
and it will result in delays and some
other services
and then we also have six existing
civilian positions
these positions are required for
administrative support to the troops
on the troopers and also direct delivery
of public safety services
and um the work for this all the all
this work would have to be reassigned
in many cases it would get reassigned to
troopers and again
we we don't like to shift administrative
duties to a mission
uh public safety service mission
delivery person so
we want to avoid that at all costs we
also
have the replacement vehicle plan
so we would be seeking an additional 1.5
million
in 22 1.6 and 23 to fund and
another 28 cruisers um our our
cruiser plan um requires us to have
about 410 vehicles for 355
troopers and that's because um a trooper
without a vehicle can't perform
their their duty i mean that's that's a
key piece of equipment
without the right number of spare
vehicles when a trooper has to bring
their car in for service they can no
longer
patrol um and those spare vehicles have
to be
available um across the state because we
have the statewide footprint so it's not
going to help us to have a spare vehicle
up at twin mountain if it's needed down
in key um
and so that's the number of vehicles
that we're looking for
um each year we're each budget cycle
we're unable to
to purchase the amount that we need to
really meet that threshold
and most recently we've had our own
orders reduced because of
shortages that were because of the
pandemic there were shortages in
supplies and materials and so our orders
have been reduced
by six vehicles here to three vehicles
there which doesn't sound like
a lot but when you filter that in over
time with a replacement plan
that has a significant burden to us so
um
we do have replacement vehicles budgeted
these would be additional vehicles to
help us meet our um
our replacement plan goals and then
detective bureau over time
this is an area that we've always
struggled with um
it's uh to meet demands for services uh
investigative services major crime
investigations
there's the work has to be done
and um and it has to be done as soon as
possible after the event
um and um there's very little control
that we have it's not like a typical
administrative function where you have
more control over overtime
there's less control in these in these
cases and so an additional 150
000 in each year would would put us at a
spot where we'd feel more comfortable
um if not we have to rely on vacancies
and
um and potentially transfers to to fund
any overage in
overtime that we might have to meet
demands for service
representative petrie you have a
question
yes yes madam chair uh thank you uh
all-wheel drive vehicles is that what
you're replacing the vehicles with
or as many as you can yes
the the the new cruiser build that we
utilize uh the chargers are all wheel
drives now
and why is that if i may
uh well the state police are uh respond
to the motor vehicle
crashes on snowy days kind of like i
don't know if it's doing where you guys
are but it's snowing in concord now
and um and so having the all-wheel drive
is is really critical if they're
the first responders to uh to any motor
vehicle accidents on on
snowy on the snowy roadways very good
thank you representative
we also purchased tahoes um
for the troopers in the north country
and i in one trip to colebrook i was
surprised to learn that it was the uh
it was the mud that troopers couldn't
even get their car their driveway they
were leaving them
at i believe colbert pd so but we didn't
have the funds to get everybody one so
we uh
you know the all-wheel drive that's what
we're migrating to and for the troopers
up in the north country
um when we can we've given them a
four-wheel drive tahoe
representative heath you have a question
i do actually it's a request
um thank you madam chair is it possible
to get this presentation i know we have
it virtually
digitally but is it possible to get a
hard copy i
find this format very useful in terms of
when we're going to be working on the
budget
um to see what we could
include in the budget if if there's any
way possible that it could be mailed to
us
or if we could i i wouldn't even mind
picking it up in um
concord if it's uh
nikki can you take care of that for us
yeah so uh the the department of
transportation budget book that they
referred to this morning i should be
getting hard copies of that
so i can put in the uh the department of
safety presentation
and mail that out to you later that's
perfect thank you so much
it's just hard to have everything
digitally because we've that
we have to have all these different
computers open to
see the information that we need
it's just nice to have a hard copy i
understand
so vicky we'll get you copies um so that
you can include it in your mailing
uh i can produce steve it's okay you
don't have to worry about that i can
i can run copies at the office and i
appreciate
that though make sure they're in color
there you go we'll charge you we'll
charge the color copies up to you
okay so um moving on we've only got
maybe four divisions left so we're about
halfway there
um the division of homeland security and
emergency management
is responsible for coordinating the
state's response to all
major um human-caused or natural
disasters
and they um they really form the core of
our emergency response organization in
the state so they operate the emergency
operations center
whenever it needs to be activated during
major disaster events
and this uh this division led by
director jen harper
has been really instrumental in our
clovid19 response function across the
state so
the role of hsem if you think about it
really is coordination
um they bring the right people to the
table to make sure that um
we can respond to disasters across the
state and
um since this has started they've been
an integral part of that
response it's really been incredible to
see
and um and be part of so
they're broken into really four sections
the operations sections
monitors the day-to-day activities
incidents and events that are happening
in new hampshire that could require some
sort of
response so they'll be monitoring
whether to see if it
rises to a degree that requires some
sort of action on the state's behalf
they operate the state emergency
operations center when it
when it is operational which serves as
the command and control center for the
state during
emergency and inner issues and then they
support interagency coordination
and also state statewide executive
decision-making authorities in response
to
uh disasters and events
the field services section is
responsible for outreach to
local communities and state agencies uh
and they provide technical
and assist organizational assistance for
preparing to and responding to
um hazards for mitigating
natural or human-caused disasters and
emergencies
and the field representatives within
this section they also act as liaisons
with local communities when the eoc
is is activated the planning and grant
section
they carry out the critical
administrative and management functions
related to the federal grants that are
administered by hsem
these include hazard mitigation grants
um
and assistance to local emergency
efforts and disaster aids the
public assistance grants as well this
section
develops the annual update for the state
emergency operations plan
the recovery annex the state hazard
mitigation plan
and then also the stakeholder
preparedness reviews
and then also we have the administrative
section which includes the office of the
director and the business and finance
staff
and community outreach office and so
they help to provide overarching
leadership to
the rest of the areas from an
administrative perspective
representative petrie did you have a
question
no madam chair that was a mistake oh no
problem
the governor's recommended budget for fy
is 17.1 million dollars which is a 63.9
percent increase over 21
and 17.3 million dollars in fy 23 which
is a 1.1 percent increase over
fy22 that increase
is due to increased disaster money
estimated disaster money and support
for um ongoing state and local disasters
including covid19
so in the past we really haven't done a
good job of estimating our disaster
grants and budgeting for them we've
always relied on going through the
fiscal committee process
whenever a disaster occurred because um
well for a while they were few and far
between
uh recently they've been coming fast and
furious
and so we decided that it's best if we
adapt
if we if we estimate some funding moving
forward for disasters
which would help to ensure that we get
the money out the door faster without
going through the fiscal
committee process outside of the budget
development process
and so that's what this represents are
those increased estimates
most of these are dealing with covid
because we are expecting those
expenditures to continue into the future
uh into the future years and then who
knows if there's another disaster
that we'll be dealing with there this um
in hsem there are two uh existing
full-time positions within the
operations section that are unfunded
um both of these positions provide
support to
the eoc efforts um and and also the
responses to locals for aid
including the radiological emergency
response activities that are associated
with seabrook station
uh we really need these positions to
prevent reductions in training and
exercise opportunities for staff for
state agencies and local communities
so again no programs would be impacted
or
cut but there would be reductions in our
ability to provide those types of
training services to
to the locals without these two
positions
representative murray you have a
question thank you madam chair
uh cohen won't last forever but there
will be other emergencies
do you have a sense of how much of this
12 million from the federal will
continue
uh you know beyond into like into the
next biennium um or is this money just
for the next two years
any any sense about any idea
um it no
the real answer is no um it's it's
really an estimate
um based off of um what we're seeing as
far as spending
and and reimbursement requests but if if
so i'll give you an example if um best
case scenario
we head into 22 covet expenditures start
going away
we've got this thing covered maybe in 23
there's one big snowstorm that requires
disaster assistance
maybe we don't need the 12.2 and it's
only it's only 6 million
i mean at that point the federal money
needs to come into the state anyway for
us to spend it
but if worst case scenario
there's new variants covet ends up being
something we live with for another year
or so
in a different capacity we likely would
need that full that full 12 million
and there's a very good chance also that
we need
20 million but we won't know that until
other new disasters hit
so we tried to we tried to create an
estimate that was reasonable
but the reality is we don't have a lot
of good um precise way to estimate these
funds at this time
you know steve there's a lot there's a
lot of important things that are done
there
at hsem like steve said the eoc but the
administrative work that's going to be
required for the next couple of years on
this reimbursement
i mean tremendous amount of work that's
going to continue
you know no matter when uh not only on
the state side but on on the local side
so
um so there's just a lot being done over
there and the director is doing a
doing a very good job and they've been
working pretty much
you know many times seven days a week so
we're hoping there's some light at the
end of the tunnel but there won't be for
the administrative work for a while
yep um so that's it so those are the two
uh the funding gaps that if funds were
available we would request
we would request support for next
division is the division of emergency
services and communications
they oversee our statewide 9-1-1 system
9-1-1 is obviously most of us know
that's the number you use for
emergencies
you call 9-1-1 you can text from any
phone
and you'll be connected with dispatch
within minutes of any type of emergency
caller id technology helps us to
identify
people can't speak and they're calling
9-1-1 so we can um
we can identify that there's there might
be a need to send someone to follow up
there's two um redundant public safety
answering point
system call centers psaps is what we
call them we've got one in concord one
in laconia
um so we have a backup and what's
interesting about these two psaps
is that um they are both operational at
all times
so anyone within laconia could pick up a
call just like anyone in concord could
pick up a call
so it's better than even a hut site
that's ready to go
it's it's active at any point in time
so it's really a it's really a great
system that we have
the division is split into um several
different areas
we've got an assistant director that
oversees the technical support and data
operations
sections this is really the um the
infrastructure that we need behind the
911 system
so the technical support maintains and
supports the
actual call system the 911
next generation call center systems also
all the connections that we have with
the dispatch agencies across the state
the data operations center
they are they deal with all the
databases that run
behind these systems to give the
telecommunicators the information
to determine where to send these calls
to to provide information to dispatch to
make sure that we get
help as soon as possible and so that
includes the
automatic location information database
that's the ali
and then also the the the gis database
it's a
geographic information system um
the other thing that uh runs in data
operations are
um the statewide emergency notification
system whereas kind of the reverse 911
where
that information gets sent out that
there's there's an emergency that people
need to be aware of
the the operations section is the area
that runs the psaps
and again those are those are redundant
systems so there's robust reliability
and they're far enough away that only in
a
um really severe um
issue would we not have survivability of
one location
it's only the most catastrophic issues
but but those calls are always coming in
and
they're open 24 7 uh seven days a week
365.
the bureau of opera interoperability
um that's managed by the swic the
statewide interoperability coordinator
and they are responsible for overseeing
the development
of um interoperability within our
communication systems across the state
um and so that's um there's training for
first responders that's that's involved
um there's coordination of frequencies
and and solutions for
um different technologies that that may
not communicate well with each other
there's emergency alert messaging
coordination
and really connecting all federal state
and local communication needs into a
single
coordinated response so that um anyone
can talk to anyone that that's the
ultimate goal
and as you can imagine that's that's a
challenge um with radio and
communications just
as much as as it is with other
technologies and then within
um that area as well is the radio
communication maintenance function
and so they they actually engineer and
install
um as well as conduct maintenance on all
of the
um radio system towers and equipment
that we have on towers
that are on leased tower space so that
includes our statewide
microwave backhaul system and all the
support facilities associated
with those the generators that keep the
um keep the towers operational and power
goes out
they they support two-way radio voice
and data communication infrastructure
uh that's owned and operated by all the
divisions in the department
um and there's also other state and
local public safety partners that they
that they assist with as well steve i
just want
i wanted to add i know that's a mouthful
but i mean when you think just
really is 911 communications statewide
and they have really expanded the
footprint
the training but when we went through
all the um
demonstrations and events over the
summer they had a
you know communications truck that went
out they downloaded all our uh
helicopter video
they made sure that you know all the
events at the you know the command sites
were streamed back to
the emergency operations center so they
really have uh
and so the division the governor's re
recommended budget for the division of
emergency services and communications
for fy 22
is 16.7 million dollars which is a 3.2
percent increase
over 21. and it's uh for 23 it's 17.4
million dollars which is a 4.5
increase over fy 22. these funds are
supported by the 911 fund
that's the 75 cent surcharge in your
phone bills
um and that supports this area of that
increase 700 000 is due to salary and
benefit changes
um in fy 23 and then an uh
fy 22 516 000
are due to opera new operating costs
increased operating costs
as well as doit support and service
agreement costs for the new
p25 compliant land mobile radial system
so we had a
we had a capital project that completed
uh
last year which updated all of our radio
system
to be um interoperable following this
p25 compliance
uh requirements and so that system's now
up and running
but that also requires service contracts
for all the equipment and software that
runs behind the system
and so those costs are included here the
operating costs also
include some support for the new mutual
link
interoperability system that was
purchased
using cares act funding it was purchased
to help
us to communicate securely with um
with the different cova 19 response
areas whether that was testing centers
vaccine distribution centers
alternate care facilities all those
different areas
this system allowed us to combine video
data all sorts of different
disparate data streams in one area so we
could coordinate statewide
um and so moving forward that's going to
be very useful
system for us to maintain as a state
so question on the uh
the 911 fund
is like a dedicated fund that just
provides money for the emergency service
and communications division
that's correct yeah for emergency
and so there's there's enough money in
there to cover
all the needs there's enough money in
there to cover all the needs
yes yes um we did
uh we did as i mentioned we had moved a
portion of the
dispatch expenses um to charge against
the fund as well
there's not enough to really sustain
that in a long-term capacity
um but there's enough to sustain that in
the 22-23 budget
so we're going to start getting into
these areas now where we've made some
funding adjustments
to uh ensure that public safety services
are funded in 2223 but we've had to make
some decisions because of lack of
funding related to general funds and
this that that was one of them okay
um the other interesting part too i'd
like to draw your attention to
is um you know we're all people driven
all the divisions are and the whole
department is but
9-1-1 especially is they've got 77
percent of costs
are associated with uh salaries and
benefits i mean that's a significant
piece
and so we it's it's great that we're
fully funded we fully funded all of our
full-time positions in this division
so we don't have any additional uh
requests uh
next we move on to the division of fire
standards and training
and ems the division
uh we call it f-stems for short so the
division is committed to
training educating and certifying
emergency and community responders
to protect the citizens and visitors of
new hampshire
and they cover a vast demographic of
first responders including firefighters
ems providers public works and citizen
volunteers
the bureau of fire fighting firefighter
training
oversees all fire and rescue
certifications
they conduct trainings um at the concord
fire academy
and then also at our north country
facility in bethlehem
and then they also are mobile so they
will bring props
and conduct certain trainings uh
statewide so if there's a local
department
that needs training and can't make it to
concord or bethlehem
we can go to them and conduct training
in their in their neck of the woods the
bureau of emergency medical services is
responsible for coordinating
emergency medical and trauma services uh
that includes managing
the training testing the licensing of
ems
providers and instructors and training
agencies and dispatchers
so they're they're really kind of an
oversight role there
the division is also responsible for
collecting data
and performing administrative
investigations of those
licensees the bureau of certification
and support
really is providing that administrative
function for those two other areas
making sure that things are scheduled
and documented
and captured appropriately and tracked
and then there's some special projects
and compliance work that
also happens in the division um you know
the ems regional court
ensuring we've got coordination with our
ems regional partners
the the heart safe communities program
which is um making sure the aeds are
available
for communities across the state uh and
then project first which is a grant
funded
program that connected individuals who
had uh
an overdose with uh treatment resources
uh within their communities and also
training families on narcan
administration to help try and get that
individual
to that treatment facility before an
the division of fire standards and
training budget requests for
fy 22 is 8.2 million dollars which is a
five percent decrease
over fy 21 and 8.3 million dollars
uh which is a one percent well just
under one percent increase over
fy 22 218 thousand dollars in
of the decrease in 22 is due to
a decline in part-time salaries
and 208 000 increase in 23 is due to the
salary and benefit
increments and the 27th pay period so
that's what's causing the increase the
uh
22 decrease of 216 thousand dollars and
168 000 decrease in 23
are due to miscellaneous decreases in
operating costs
associated with the delivery of training
programs um
this is also a division where we've
fully funded all
uh all positions you look at the funding
source the vast majority is funded from
the fire fund here
so the fire fund um is utilized to
support
this division uh for the fire academy
fire
and ems and also the division of fire
safety
we had to reduce some part-time salaries
here in fire standards and training
because those general fund concerns that
we had prior
forced us to change the funding of the
fire safety division which is the fire
marshal's office
which we'll see as the next division
because the fire marshal in the last
budget
we had moved partially onto the general
fund about 50 50
because last budget we were
we were speaking to the committee and
explaining that the fire fund can no
longer support both of these divisions
the revenue stream is flat the revenues
are collected from
motor vehicle record requests primarily
from insurance companies looking to do
business
and and unfortunately that's not a high
growth
area it's it's a flat it's as consistent
and steady revenue stream
but like our other divisions the cost of
doing business keeps increasing
so a flat revenue stream doesn't help us
when costs are increasing even if it's
not at
an exorbitant rate of increase so
one of the reductions we had to make
because we moved the fire marshal back
onto the fire fund
100 was to reduce part-time salaries in
uh f-stems these part-time employees are
the instructors
so these this will result in a reduction
in course offerings
um this will be partially offset with
move to
online course development so fire
standards and training has been looking
to incorporate online trainings
either in whole or even in part within
their existing
criteria and so that'll reduce the costs
of some of the courses that they offer
but at the end of the day there will be
a reduction where that is will depend on
demand
so first and foremost we want to make
sure we offer firefighter one
firefighter two the certification
courses because those
are required to be a full-time
firefighter in the state of new
hampshire
um but it's the other courses that that
might be um
like uh um the ladder truck how to
operate the ladder truck
um specialty i'm making some things up
i'm getting outside my
uh direct knowledge on these things but
there's other
specialty type of trainings uh that that
won't be offered
or would be reduced in its offering um
and so that that's one of the results of
of the funding concerns that's impacted
uh fire standards and training
well you know what stephen i want to add
you a spot on but we had to
uh limit some of the training through
cole but as you know
a lot of the building was used for
different cobot related events so
there's going to be a big need moving
forward to get these classes up and
running
and which the director's paying
attention
to all right
and then last but not least uh the
division of fire safety
the mission of the division of fire
safety is to prevent death's injury and
property loss by promoting a safe fire
building and hazardous materials
environment in new hampshire
and they do this by through education
engineering
investigation and enforcement and the
division investigates all fires
and building collapses and carbon
monoxide releases other than automobiles
so carbon monoxide releases in buildings
which cause deaths and assist any local
fire chief
law enforcement or local governing board
when assistance is requested
so they're broken into four sections the
bureau of investigations is where the
fire investigators reside
they investigate all fires and building
collapses uh
in addition they assist whenever
whenever needed
the bureau of planning and support
services
they have several functions underneath
them there's a hazmat unit which assists
communities
in developing has hazardous materials uh
hazmat emergency action plans and also
providing information
on transportation manufacturing and
storage of hazardous materials
there's firework safety and enforcement
unit which conducts inspections
investigations and other activities
for the proper use handling and storage
and transportation
of fireworks for manufacturers and the
wholesale of retail
the retail sales of fireworks also
there's a public education section
so they they manage a variety of fire
life safety education components
um things like think about um you know
remember to replace your
uh the battery in your smoke detector on
on daylight savings time so
things like that um to help people have
um a safer
fire environment in their homes and in
their work
then there's the bureau of building
safety and construction
and under that bro we've got the
engineering and plans review section
they're responsible for reviewing plans
of all the state-owned buildings
public school projects health care
facilities
anything licensed by the department of
health and human services
and they also have to inspect all
construction projects for state-owned
buildings
and that includes that includes us and
the department of safety we work closely
with them if we have a construction
project in one of our facilities
we have to also go through and get that
permitting process
the tramway amusement ride safety
section also falls
under this bureau so they oversee the
safety of the state
ski industry resources and other
amusement rides
to ensure compliance with all safety
regulations for carnival
enemies and ride operators in the state
and then the modular housing program
ensures that modular building components
are constructed
in accordance with building and fire
the budget request for the division of
fire safety for fy 22
is 4.5 million dollars which is a 14.9
percent decrease from 21
and 4.6 million dollars in fy 23 which
is a one percent increase
over fy 22. um the largest
reason for this decline has to do with a
change in the mechanical licensing
function
so this budget transfers the mechanical
licensing function
into the office of professional
licensure and certification
in fy 22 we work closely with um
with oplc to to make that happen and
both both departments felt that it was
the right choice
um and that's where it belonged um you
can see
from the funding here as i mentioned
before in the past in 20 and 21
the fire marshal had 2.4 and 2.9 million
dollars worth of general funds
uh to support their budget those funds
um
we had to make the difficult decision to
fund all the other
areas that we've talked about and we
still had um
have some funding gaps um regardless we
we removed the general funding from the
fire marshal
so their functions are in the um
are in are in the fire fund now what's
left has to do with the modular building
function the modular building function
is a is a
what we refer to as a 125
generally funded area where we need to
collect 125 percent
of our expenditures um in in general
funds
and so that's what's left that small bit
um the uh all the positions within fire
safety have been funded the full-time
positions
are all there there were reductions in
part-time funding
in this division as well and that's
again that will result in delays in some
of the building and
life safety inspection and plan reviews
that they're trying to complete
but the programs themselves will
i am happy i'm happy to hear that you uh
moved the what whatever you call it
mechanical licensing yeah that's been uh
that's been going on for how long to
actually move that but uh i'm glad to
hear it's happened
so representative bucco you have a
question
yeah yes thank you
what is the source of the fire fund
what is the social revenue of the fire
fund the fire fund revenues
come from um motor vehicle history
records
that are requested by mostly by
insurance companies
driving history records thank you
um so
before i conclude here um just the very
last page
which is appendix a and it's been
referred to throughout the presentation
when when we uh presented uh at the
governor's budget hearing
representative ober had requested that
we provide a crosswalk of two areas that
we had mentioned
one is retiree health the allocation and
the changes we made
and the other is doit so we provided
that crosswalk here
for your reference essentially what this
shows
is how in um we we took
the retiree health costs which were
being um
the vast majority were being funded by
the highway fund and we allocated them
across
all the accounting units where the
individuals worked
originally to um to spread those costs
to the dedicated funds uh wherever
possible
again to help to help reduce our draw
from the highway fund because of the
concerns with revenue
similar to retiree health we did the
same thing with doit
we looked at the services being received
and we allocated those
some on pc count some based on
what types of systems are operated by
the division and allocated those
across the area and that's why you see
some fluctuations that are big between
admin and state police and some
fluctuations between the commissioner's
office and some other areas
so this was a request at that time so we
provide this information for you so you
can
you can take a look at that if you're so
interested
but the key thing just in summary as the
commissioner mentioned
in his opening remarks um you know our
our
our mission to continue to enhance
public safety and security in new
hampshire
it's going to continue with this budget
um we're a large department
it's important everything that we do i i
hope you've seen the breadth of services
that are provided here
and and the governor's recommended
budget does provide us with the
funding we need to maintain public
safety and we're not stopping anything
however however there are reductions and
delays in service that are going to
happen
um because of these unfunded positions
and that's why
you know we do formally request if
there's funding available that that's
available to this committee that you
could really strongly consider funding
these positions
um if anything becomes available during
this phase in the budget process
and uh be happy to answer any additional
questions that
that you may have yeah uh representative
murray you had a question
thank you again um are your priorities
pretty much focused on personnel i think
before someone asked about you coming up
with the priorities of if we have to
choose which
um positions to fill uh you would give
us
uh direction on that um are there other
areas that are non-personnel that you
um their their commissioner you can jump
in at any time but they're primarily
personnel
costs um the the big exception
uh being the state police fleet
and that's that's that's gonna be a
balance um
and so so there's not a depending on the
funding that's available
will will likely change what that
priority becomes
i was going to say the same thing the
representative heath you have a question
thank you madam chair um
and my question is for commissioner
quinn
commissioner this is a tough budget
um monies have been moved around and it
seems like it's kind of pieced together
do you really think that you're really
gonna be able to adequately
perform the job that you need to do
based on the amount of dollars that have
been provided
well we're doing it we're doing it today
and um
you know if you look at the slide that's
up there um
we created this as an agency almost two
years ago
and we have seven divisions and together
senior leadership came up with those
that vision and mission statement and um
and what i what i say at every new
onboarding
i try and meet every new employee there
isn't a position here that's
more more important we all have
different titles and
different salaries and grades but you
know look at steve lavoy
um nobody would understand better than
me and you you know the impact he has on
public safety
and whether you're in uh the back office
of uh dmv
processing financial responsibility or
you're you know you're leading the swat
team
um they're all equally important so
i can tell you that the budget's one
thing
the people are another so we have good
good people
and you know um and they're doing their
job today as steve said
we believe that we can uh we can deliver
but
um as stated there's certain areas that
uh
um that might need uh more attention
or where you know some of the services
might be delayed but um
yeah every single day they're getting it
done so
so whatever help and i appreciate
division two
i wanted to say this the focus you've
had i know you've been with us now for
over two hours and i know you're looking
at it and
you know it's been like 10 years now
that i've worked with division two
and this is my first first round with
the budget so
um you know steve tried to put forward
with me it was
it's conservative it's realistic the
other thing is
every one of these divisions we work
very close with the directors
on this and um so so understanding what
they have to do they have to try and
you know you know uphold the mission
statement so
we're going to do i will say this
they do their very best every single day
and they will continue to do it
and they appreciate whatever support you
can give them
well thank you commissioner and uh
mr lavoy this has been a very
enlightening
uh two hours and uh
we really appreciate um the time
and helping us to understand your needs
and as you can imagine we will have you
back
probably sometime next week to
delve more into the uh
details of your budget and we're
looking forward to working with you
and being doing what we can
to uh to help not only safety but
all of the other areas um that we have
to manage so
i appreciate it very very much so
thank you again thank you thank you very
much thank you everybody
yeah okay i just yep thank you
i just want to remind everybody
that we have um doe tomorrow
um i'm sure that will be uh
very interesting as well and
um then wednesday and thursday we're in
session and then on friday
we're going to have the university and
community college system in
so i know it's going to be a long week
and a lot of stuff going on but um
we've got to get we got to get through
this budget somehow or other so
uh did you have a question mary i do
madam chair thank you for taking my
question
i also have a accounting meeting so i'm
gonna be having two computers going
i'm gonna be at both meetings at the
same time
but i i may have to divert a little bit
to vote
um for our county meeting i think we
have a lot to talk about
but i will be there okay okay yeah i
know
i know um i uh i'm i'm running into
those problems as well
but uh you know you got to do what you
got to do
so that's fine uh representative murray
uh oh thank you um i have my coverage
shot
on friday at two will university or
education
be done by then do you think i can't do
my shop virtually so
yeah yeah but i don't know if we'll be
done by
probably we'll leave here by 1 30 or so
uh that's a that's a very good question
i
i'm just really really not sure well
i will hang on as long as i can and try
to
bring my phone with me to listen in if i
can but i will have to leave by 1 30 to
get my cova
not missing my covet vaccine no is this
your first or second
my first ah okay well
good luck i had my second one on uh on
saturday so
how did you feel they say the second
one's more side effect
i had i had no problem whatsoever with
either one of them
i mean other than you know the show
where they put the shot in that it was
sore but that was it
that hardly counts yeah yeah it did to
me it didn't count
representative lynn yes just uh a quick
question
just procedurally do you want me to
write up a little something about these
two things or since we're having them
come back next week should i wait until
then um i just write up a little thing
that says
you know we met with the uh okay you
know
and they explained i don't know that's
fine i just didn't wasn't sure what the
what the process was but that's fine
i'll do that that it doesn't have to be
very long-winded at all okay all right
great thank you
yep uh does anyone else have anything
for the good of the order okay
seeing nothing we'll uh talk to you
tomorrow morning at
10 o'clock take care yeah bye